recebi com muita honra muita alegria
esse convite poder participar estudantes
professores da unila é uma universidade
parceira nossa é uma alegria estar aqui
com vocês vamos 18 minutos para passar
um pouquinho da mensagem da nossa
experiência é eu me formei como ele como
grupo e falou em medicina na federal do
paraná mas quando estava no sexto ano de
medicina e eu comecei a olhar primeiro
para a minha trajetória e poxa vida eu
quero
são 8 mil e 400 horas de curso 97% das
aulas sobre doenças 3% sobre saúde
nenhuma aula sobre gente que foi nossa
tristeza da medicina para lidar com
gente nunca tive uma aula sobre gente né
meus colegas em uma simples aquele
paciente ele tem uma estratégia e tática
o fígado dele eu sei tratar mas ele vai
junto com o fígado complica a minha vida
ele podia ficar em casa e mandar o
fígado para o consultório eu não sei o
que fazer com ele só sei o que fazer com
o fígado dele e aí essas coisas fui
pensando essencial de uma coisa eu vou
mudar minha vida fui dar uma palestra na
escola sobre como o cérebro aprende
adorei fazer aquilo chega em casa feliz
da vida disse para minha família
já sei o que você como assim se formando
aqui há dois meses residência para
neurologia está vindo você vai ser
neurologista 2 anos que já estuda
neurologia
você mudou para mim mesmo card o gasto
não não eu não vou ser médico e
professor foi uma decepção coletiva na
minha família como assim doido de um
psiquiatra
não quero ser médico é ser professor
quer orientar as pessoas querem viajar
pelo mundo quer conhecer gente eu quero
aprender eu quero vivenciar eu quero ser
um professor mas um outro tipo diferente
de professor do que está aí e fui
não tive medo deixei a medicina tem
alguns professores aqui na ilha foram
meus colegas de turma na medicina mas
deixei a medicina bananeira neurologia e
foi com educação e 25 anos estou na
educação
tentando entender como é que faz 25 anos
que o estudo tentando aprender como é
que as pessoas aprendem tentando
aprender como é que se dá a formação que
uma pessoa de verdade o que tem valor
para aprendizagem para a vida pra
felicidade para o sucesso pra esses
elementos todos e aí depois de 25 anos
trabalhando com isso com mais de 500
universidades cinco países
a gente veio para foz do iguaçu e falei
vamos fazer
uma experiência diferente aqui em foz
vamos fazer uma experiência diferente
das universidades tradicionais tentando
trazer os conhecimentos da neurociência
das vivências que a gente já teve
o que a gente aprendeu nos estados
unidos na alemanha os países
escandinavos vão trazer o brasil vamos
ver o que a gente consegue fazer
vamos ver o que a gente é capaz de fazer
dessa realidade e aí pra provocar vocês
eu trouxe esse tema será que o modelo de
universidade chegou ao fim mas porque as
pessoas estão comentando e criticando
isso a universidade está aí
a universidade é centenária a
universidade é importantíssimo na
formação das pessoas nós estamos
trabalhando com a educação com o ensino
superior então por que esse
questionamento que o modelo tradicional
chegou ao fim
na verdade a universidade não chegou
assim mas o modelo que ela faz está se
tornando obsoleto se a gente não fizer
alguma coisa para mudar isso vai
isso vai nos preocupar isso vai fazer
com que a gente perca espaço não é em
todas as áreas está acontecendo que ele
vê um caso interessante
a google apple e ibm elas publicaram um
documento onde elas dizem que ela não
exige mais diploma de curso superior
para contratar ninguém
é um recado que elas deram para
faculdades olha vocês não estão formando
um profissional legal então faz
diferença se ele tem diploma não vou
contratar baseado em outros elementos
que não esses seguirão carona outras e
outras empresas seguiram carona com isso
aí você tem algumas aqui desde banco até
hotéis está todo mundo entrando nessa
onda e não exige mais diploma para fazer
a seleção de um profissional né porque
isso porque esse recado que o mundo está
dando para as universidades que a
sociedade está dando para as
universidades olha vocês têm que
repensar o que estão fazendo não é o
senhor da google falou não o diretor vp
de rh da google falou assim a capacidade
cognitiva geral capacidade cognitiva
tantas habilidades cognitivas não
cognitivas no geral são mais importantes
do que a titulação da pessoa
o vice-presidente da apple falou que
mostrou estudos de que as provas feitas
nas faculdades não são um bom elemento
para predizer o desempenho profissional
da pessoa uma pessoa com boas notas não
quer dizer que será um bom profissional
e assim vai
o que o senhor da ibm também colocou os
motivos pelos quais não exigem mais
os profissionais mas aí o que significa
sair junto a isso junta o mercado de
trabalho com as pesquisas da
neurociência ea neurociência 25 anos em
falando para os educadores por
dirigentes universidade olha alguém
aprender de verdade precisa fazer três
coisas estudar eles interagir com quem
sabe fazer
ele precisa fazer tá bom e daí que eu
faço com isso é montar seu currículo em
cima disso os currículos das
universidades não são montados assim não
são feitos dessa forma as pessoas não
fazem um show em teoria não vem prática
federal do rio grande do sul fez uma
pesquisa mostrando que é um estudante
sai do ensino superior 45 anos depois
com capacidade de replicar 37 por cento
do que foi ensinado replicar na teoria
37% o que foi ensinado
mas na prática só certo só 7% do que foi
ensinado gente 45 anos para conseguir
aplicar 7% de tudo que foi visto no
curso superior não tem alguma coisa
errada com isso me parece muito
inteligente esse investimento de tempo
para um resultado tão ruim assim né
e assim nós vamos indo né a formação
efetiva há uma coisa que está ajudando a
mudar o mundo
essa charge ilustra bem isso o que aliás
já diz assim o cara foi no
confessionário foi o padre o pt eo pdt
facebook aberto já tô sabendo meu filho
é ninguém mais esconde nada de ninguém
até aí não é novidade para nós todos né
nossa vida está aberta
se a gente não possa no facebook alguém
posta que a gente fez lá então a gente
virou refém agora das redes sociais mas
não é isso que essa charge eu trouxe a
chave não por isso em todas as áreas
para dizer que o acesso universal à
informação ele é um fato
se você quiser assistir uma aula hoje
sobre é escolher em que o exemplo mais
claro em que mann da botânica você
encontra pelo menos uma centena de aulas
de qualquer de vários lugares do mundo
diversos professores têm uma da usp
mandando em campo e uma da unifesp uma
gestão foi o mais rápido você vai
encontrar tudo tudo tudo gratuitamente
antes não era assim que funcionava antes
você depende de um professor para passar
informação hoje ninguém mais pensa de
professor para passar informação
professora virou uma peça chave funda
mental no aprendizado efetivo - para
passar informação para isso não é mais
dele mas para o resto toda a gente
precisa de professor mas que resto todo
esse calma vou chegar lá
nós temos ainda o uso inadequado da
tecnologia tecnologia pode vir para nos
ajudar não pra não para fazer mais do
mesmo né
a legislação brasileira ainda confunde
as coisas um objeto desse tamanho é a
realização brasileira chama de educação
presencial uma reunião dessas é ead né
eu não eu chamo esse efetivo de educação
de longa distância nem a de é de longa
distância e uma interação como essa um
cara na califórnia outro cara na em
paris na frança conversando trocando
idéias experiências e vivências
eu chamo isso de presencial ou
telepresencial
mas a regulação ainda não acompanha isso
e no futuro nem mais vai existir é ead
a tecnologia já permite interações hoje
de todos os tipos e essa dicotomia entre
cursos à distância e cursos presenciais
vão desaparecer totalmente essas que o
time vai desaparecer desculpe não
existirão mais cursos presenciais nem
cursos à distância e serão cursos
mediado com componentes mediado por
tecnologia e componentes presenciais
mas o que é mediado por tecnologia o que
é presencial mediado por tecnologia é
tudo aquilo que eu não preciso mais de
um papagaio de pirata chegou o professor
de administração na américa disse olha
região que slides bonitos eu fiz sobre
as cinco forças competitivas de michael
porter para explicar os alunos e foi
tudo bem mas perdeu seu tempo não é você
que vai explicar esse aluno foi porque
não porque é o mico porta que vai ficar
pra ele o cara que criou isso
ele tem o vídeo do porta eu tenho o
livro do potter eu tenho tudo ali não só
de você pra isso não é que eu vou fazer
então você vai pegar você vai fazer
compreender isso ele vai contextualizar
ele vai aplicar o supermercado muffato
está competindo aqui para entender o
poder dos fornecedores barganha clientes
você vai dar pra ajudar da
aplicabilidade porque sem aplicabilidade
não aprende só a teoria não é suficiente
para fazer ninguém aprender então pra
isso que você vai trabalhar você
professor e não para explicar aquilo
esse modelo de sala de aula é uma
excrescência não pode mais ser aceito
não pode mais ser demitido é passado
isso acabou
eu demorei para entender como é que ele
só escrevi em todos os lados do quadro
mas o quadro se mexe tem quatro
quadrantes ali né
mas isso isso é só um filme de televisão
antigo mundo real não permite mais esse
tipo de coisa nem deseja esse tipo de
coisa hoje as salas são diferentes
crianças adultos make up spaces sala de
trabalho computadores e principalmente
em ambientes foras aprendizagem
vivenciais fora do campus nas
comunidades nas empresas nas indústrias
na sociedade de modo geral
você vai aprender a onde está sendo
vivenciado aquele conhecimento você vai
estudar em bloco a coisa acontecendo de
verdade né isso isso efetivamente é a
proposta das universidades de hoje você
vai estudar engenharia de alimentos numa
indústria de alimentos como a gente tem
uma unidade lá dentro mental você vai
estudar farmácia numa indústria
farmacêutica como a gente tem unidades
na prática donaduzzi você vai para os
laboratórios e vai pra vida você vai
para o mundo
você vai interagir e vai vivenciar você
vai conhecer e compreender e não apenas
ficar assistindo aula porque você ficar
assistindo aula
você não vai muito longe você já ouviu
falar no salman khan daquele criador da
cana academy salman khan se tornou uma
personalidade de lúcia depois que o bill
gates e levou a um dos grandes papas da
educação pela pela criação da cana
academy e os allman e escrever um livro
e chamado um mundo é uma escola e tem um
capítulo do livro ele fala trajetória
dele ele foi estudante do haiti
para quem conhece entre as três melhores
do mundo é melhor das engenharias do
mundo ele disse assim foi fantástico e
cinco anos que passei mártir foi
maravilhoso foram maravilhosos foi um
divisor de águas na minha vida mas valeu
muito a pena principalmente porque é eu
aproveitei muito e mantinha não passei
eu não passei um tempo assistindo aula
por isso eu consegui aproveitar a noite
que estivesse todas as aulas e teria
perdido os cinco anos e meio de
oportunidade de interagir com o haiti
olha que a mensagem está passando com
isso olha o que ele está dizendo que
está acontecendo no mundo né é diferente
de e de ilegal
aqui é um elemento muito importante a
gente compreender porque se você
assistir à sua aula você pode conhecer
muitas coisas
o professor vai passar muita informação
para você e se ele for bom você vai
comprar
ver aquilo só que o aprendizado efetivo
acontecer você tem que aplicar o que
você está compreendendo se você não
aplicar se você não analisar se você não
avaliar e criar a partir daquilo que
compreendeu aprendizado efetivo não se
dá e se você ficar só assistindo aula só
vai só vai ficar nesse patamar aqui
então não adianta ficar parado em aulla
aula um expediente relevante mas
complementar e secundário no processo de
aprendizagem e isso que as universidades
têm que entender e é isso que faz com
que elas mudem de fato o modelo das
universidades
o professor não é mais o sábio no palco
não é mais aquele que desfila o seu
saber para os alunos passivos escutarem
professor é aquele que senta junto com o
aluno e compartilha sua vivência fez
entrar em uma sala de aula da américa
você não sabe quem é o professor não
existe uma mesa do professor uma cadeira
do professor professor sentado na mesa
com os alunos com outros profissionais
da comunidade
cheguei lá onde nada de arquitetura
estava o professor estava o secretário
de obras do município secretário do meio
ambiente do município um arquiteto
paisagista amigo dele e um colega da
turma lhe que trabalha com harry tinha
cinco pessoas de fora da comunidade
trabalhando com os alunos porque não tem
aula expositiva tem trabalho tem
projetos em elaboração tem criação de
conhecimento feito pelos alunos
orientados pelos professores e por
mentores da comunidade um
compartilhamento de conhecimento
aquela hierarquia onde professor era
dono da cátedra né e o aluno o próprio
nome diz alumni sem luz néon o mestre
ilumina o seu aluno tudo isso é passado
a relação hoje é de igual para igual a
nova geração trabalha com o professor
reconhecendo o seu conhecimento e sua
experiência mas partilhando com
compartilhando com ele esse movimento e
muitos os alunos a fazerem projetos
descobrem conhecimentos descobrem
metodologias e modos de fazer o que o
professor não conhece ele a junto com o
aluno aprende coisas novas todos os dias
em todos os momentos
é um outro modelo mental de educação
onde não há mais de graus hierárquicos a
respeito sim mas não mais degraus de
hierarquia é um compartilhamento de
vivências e experiências e aprendizagem
que é o que o mundo que é hoje
o ensino hoje é híbrido sim porque nós
não somos mais receptores passivos de
informações
somos gestores a nossa própria
aprendizagem nós somos produtores do
conhecimento autores da compreensão de
mundo e compartilhamento das vivências
que a gente tem hoje na vida e a última
último ponto para a gente entender bem
isso vou dar um exemplo prático dessa
realidade
eu estava na faculdade e tive 10 horas
numa disciplina sobre anticoncepcionais
sobre anticoncepção humana uma matéria
tinha dez 12 horas sobre isso então
precisou explicando anticoncepcional
hormonal odil isso tabelinha tal era
tudo o que tínhamos e aí nós tínhamos
que depois usar isso como profissional
tenho que orientar mas se fosse um
estudo baseado em competências o que a
gente estaria aprendendo a capacidade de
orientar a melhor escolha de método
anticonceptivo considerando o contexto
sócio econômico do paciente indicações e
contra-indicações vantagens desvantagens
mas não teve nada disso o que a gente
tinha na faculdade aula sobre a
concepção da primeira vez que foi
orientar uma pessoa de anticoncepcional
comecei a explicar os vários
anticoncepcionais que ela tinha com cara
de paisagem
até que alguém me disse eu não entendo
nada que está falando
eu não tinha a habilidade de compreender
a realidade social dela e traduzir o meu
vocabulário medicaid para o mundo onde
ela compreendia
daí eu tive que desenvolver essa
habilidade fora das salas de aula pessoa
não ensina isso daí eu fui comecei a
explicar no nível do paciente daí cometi
um outro erro
passei o medicamento anticonceptivo para
a paciente que taboão legal você
entendeu falou minha língua
só que eu não podia comprar isso e não
tem no sus
você não compreender o meu contexto
sócio-econômico outra inabilidade minha
e depois tá bom com certeza essa também
desenvolve essa terceira essa segunda
habilidade
fui de novo processo pela terceira vez
daí fui eu falei do jeito certo que o
paciente entendeu fiz
analisei o contexto sócio-econômico
prescrevido jeito correto e aí onde eu
errei não teria relação empática com ela
relação interpessoal adequada ela já
tinha anticoncepcional já entendi aquilo
que eu falei
ela foi pra conversar comigo porque ela
tinha um outro problema efetivo que ela
queria compartilhar com alguém mas não
tive a sensibilidade de perceber e criar
uma relação para que ela se confiasse em
mim e conversar comigo sobre isso
olha eu falei de três habilidades duas
cognitivas de uma não cognitiva que não
for desenvolvida na faculdade que eu não
aprendi que ninguém me ensinou que o
mundo teve que ensinar o professor só
ensinou a aula teórica sobre
consecutivos até a fórmula dos
estrogénios ele passou grandes coisas
quem vai precisar de decorar fórmulas de
de do negócio e perdeu tempo com isso
tudo quando deveria estar trabalhando
essas habilidades porque é isso que eu
preciso no mundo real
desculpa dar o exemplo da medicina
mateus da outro 95% dos erros médicos o
médico são processados por erro médico
95% dos casos não é por negligência
imperícia é porque não consegue se
comunicar direito do paciente é proíbida
di de comunicação que o paciente não dá
então gente não dá pra gente ficar no
mundo
quando a gente não desenvolver essas
competências o conhecimento necessário
tudo bem conhecimento teórico é
importante eu tenho que estudar mas eu
tenho que ser capaz de discernir sobre o
método mais adequado de origem é capaz
de orientar ser capaz de criar uma
relação de empatia
se eu não for capaz disso você um
péssimo profissional eu posso saber tudo
da teoria mas eu vou ser um péssimo
profissional
e aí eu queria terminar pra vocês
dizendo assim o sucesso profissional não
garante a felicidade você ser um bom
aluno não garante o sucesso profissional
mas sim se você decidir ser feliz agora
decidi vivenciar o seu aprendizado de
verdade aí sim você vai ter muita chance
de ser muito bem sucedido que a
felicidade não é uma coisa externa é uma
decisão interna e o aprendizado é algo
que você queria que você controla não é
algo passivo que você recebe de um
terceiro que a universidade se ela for
inteligente ela muda para oferecer
oportunidade do aluno criar o seu
aprendizado e não tratá-lo como um ser
passivo que recebe orientações
informações sentado todo dia ouvindo
aulas expositivas
obrigado pela atenção de vocês